good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this
extraordinary council meeting this
evening
housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs either through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber I can confirm that the
Proceedings of this meeting will be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the internet I would also advise that if
filming takes place anyone in the in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured I urge anyone
filming proceedings to avoid filming
members of the public particularly if
there are children present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
thank you any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst the
meeting is in progress move on to the
agenda items and agenda item one is
apologies for absence and I apologize
that these are not necessarily in
alphabetical order
particularly you have if you have some
more members well clarification pleases
sharing about your opening remarks
correct me if I'm wrong you've just said
that this meeting is in Hue recorded and
broadcast on the internet and yet the
first item that we are to consider this
evening is to exclude the present public
could you tell me how things stand in
terms of FOI requests and the
and public seeing the conversations that
go on here tonight if they're to be
excluded from them tonight but not to
belittle for them at some point in the
future with no reference and no decision
as to what the frame would be to make
them accessible or not I take advise if
council Greece goes to confidential
session then the second part will not be
recorded thank you
so at that point we would expect an
officer to go to the appropriate thing
and turn the switch off then there will
be nothing else to see or hear or be
kept by this council so there'll be
nothing from the VF arrival and what on
that subject you know want to get this
out of the way
can we have an explanation says please
as to why the person probably need to it
stood on this occasion we can cover that
on the agenda item that agenda item free
and I will raise that issue then council
matter face counselor Campbell is that
here this evening sense apologies
council Piper Thank You mr. chair
councillor Bertie Braidwood
and councillor Roy Pot send apologies I
had two of them I've now got councillor
pots I'll read out the names that I have
and I again apologize for them not be in
alphabetical order
I have apologies from councillor Curran
Dickson Larkins Martin Pugh Rogers right
Parsons
LFL brass Townend Dennis Bray would
Campbell and pots and Day and Jeremy
Fairbrass thank you generalize from two
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest on this
evening's agenda items no gender no
declaration of interest so we move on to
agenda item three exclusion of press and
public I move that the recommendation as
set out in the report be adopted with
the vice chairman please second second a
chair Thank You council paper thank you
very much mr. chairman I think it may be
beneficial for members to hear both
sides of the argument for this agenda
item and I would like to make the case
if you'll permit for leaving the press
and the public in attendance but would
be happy to hear the counter-argument in
a few moments the advice we've received
is that according to the Local
Government Act 1972 schedule 12a part 1
those are the reasons being put forward
that we should exclude the press and the
public descriptions under that part one
of exempt information for England are
paragraph one information relating to an
individual mr. Chairman I think it's
rather late to try and avoid that one
too information which is likely to real
reveal the identity of an individual
likewise I think we're far too late to
avoid that one
and five which was quoted information
with respect to which a claim to legal
professional privilege could be
maintained in legal proceedings I think
it might be helpful to have some
guidance on that on page 5 of agenda
item number 3
specifically paragraph 4 1 refers I'll
just find it if I may mr. chairman
factors suggested by the Information
Commissioner's being relevant to an
assessment of public interest applying
to the information disclosure would one
further public understanding of the
issues involved I think that's quite an
important matter and three promote
accountability and transparency by the
council for the decisions it makes it
seems to me that honest open and
transparent local government are vital
it is important therefore that our
reputation as an organization is
maintained or even improved whenever the
opportunity presents itself we cannot
afford any further allegations of
perfidy for anybody and I did have to
look that up
it means dishonesty or untrustworthiness
nor should we I believe mr. chairman be
labeled as a council that acts in secret
behind closed doors for that reason my
personal preference would be to leave
the press and the public in the room
Thank You mr. chairman
I take advice but members will know from
my previous role as chairman of the
scrutiny panel that I am my a champion
of transparency but I'll ask the
monitoring officer to make the point and
then counsel madiface can we let the
monastry know seal that ask first thank
you thank you very much chairman whilst
this report is principally about the
failure to follow a required
administrative process it does include
personal data about an individual who is
identified in the report there are
therefore gdpr
and data protection issues about
publishing any
personal information which will be
unfair disclose or otherwise otherwise
breach the data protection act 2018 and
general data protection regulations in
addition to the information already
included in the report through
discussing and debating the item it is
possible and indeed our thought likely
that further information may be made
available in public relating to the
financial or business affairs of the
individual or information relating to
Rabia relations matters again relating
to that individual labor relation
matters include terms of conditions of
employment engagement or non engagement
or termination or suspension of their
duties and these are specifically
referred to in the report also with
details of offices held by individuals
and those persons contractual
relationship with the council in the
same way that we would not disclose this
information in public where it relates
for an employee in the council identical
protection is afforded to office holders
included secondes further the report and
appendices contain confidential
communication to the council and its
legal adviser which attract the
particular legal profession privilege it
is again I think likely that additional
cadre to delay information may be
imparted at the meeting and therefore I
think it's important to maintain that
legal profession privilege whilst no
legal action has yet been commenced and
respect to this matter such action
cannot be discounted and would therefore
be contrary to the council's interest to
share or discus that advice in public if
counsel decide to proceed for the
present public present that will require
detailed thought about what should and
what should not be disclosed that will
impact upon the free flow of this debate
I will not help in my view members
consideration the matter and that's rich
rate that my overriding concern is not
to protect the council but to protect
the privacy of the individual involved
our therefore ask Council to consider
this matter in the absence of present
public we obviously have considered the
policy advice on the public interest
test and it is my opinion that the
public interest in maintaining exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing this information
Thank You counselor that's a face then
counselor constant time Thank You chair
on page five public interest factors for
exemption we have one two three four six
and seven perhaps I could ask mr. house
what happened to number five I mean was
this something that wasn't considered
relevant or is this something we should
have been informed about I think our
member from democratic services is just
confirming that's a typo it's not a
deliberate omission counselor Constance
nine you had your hand up I did thank
you and thank you very much for that
outline of gdpr and other issues in
particular in relationship to labor and
their employment issues I mean of course
the protection of privacy and protection
of the individual in circumstances are
absolutely paramount I just wondered why
this wasn't actually considered at the
very beginning of this process and why
in fact we didn't receive this
information on pink in the first place
what has happened to consistency of
advice here it's all about the level of
detail and I'll talk about the level of
detail later nominal presentment report
the deficit in level of detail in my
early reports I don't think did justify
going into pink I think at that point
the public interest in destroying that
certainly outweigh the pop interested in
keeping that information silence so in
my view the situation was different
there it was a much shorter report much
more basic information this time there's
more detailed information and obviously
because it contains the council's advice
as well councillor Johnson thank you
very much chairman I have asked this
question many times but I'll ask again
the name of my fellow counselor
counselor Venables was very clearly in
every report from item 13 the first time
on the 11th of October the whole world
out there was aware of the person who
was named and described as disqualified
which in many people's understanding
outside of this council would mean
someone had done something wrong
obviously councilor Venables had done
absolutely nothing to Johnson I said old
grounds ago I watched all of this it's
like a repeat on television I watched it
all on the Internet and it's virtually
word-for-word so we need to move on
thank you you muttered to one side but I
heard you that you couldn't we couldn't
use counselor Venables name because we
were now in court now are we in court or
not because if we're in court none of us
should be talking about any of this
that's what I think you're I think
you're quoting out of context of Johnson
can you sit down and I'll explain you
had your opportunity to challenge me on
the night and quite frankly if you to
challenge me that would have been a
legitimate point of order other than all
of the other points that came up that
weren't anything to do at point of order
so we need to move on thank you I wrote
and asked you in the polite manner that
I behave and you've still not answered
me several weeks later would you answer
me tonight are we in court or not if we
were in court on this matter I've given
you the answer by being silent I've
taken advice and I am remaining silent
on that point you need to listen to the
tape watch the tape again and put it in
context thank you can we move on we're
up to a situation where I need to say do
members agree with the exclusion of the
present public in that case I'll take a
vote
can I ask if more than 50% of the
members present want a recorded vote if
you'd like to put your hands up if you
want a recorded vote those against
in that case it's a show of hands so all
those in favor of the exclusion of press
in public if you can raise your hands
now
all those against
abstentions in that case welcome to the
press in public you can remain in the
chamber and will move on to the next
agenda item and the next agenda item is
agenda item for the monitoring office's
report I call upon mr. house director of
corporate governance sorry council
mattify thank you I was able to read
this on pink but I do understand that
quite a number of councillors were not
able to access this document on pink I
don't know how many that would be I
would just like to know how many people
have actually read the monitoring
officer's report with the restricted
written across it on pink I'm not sure
that's a relevant question but I do know
that there was difficulty accessing and
the information I received were that a
lot of the councillors had gone into mod
gov but hadn't gone into Fannett private
on mod Garden therefore didn't
necessarily weren't I able to access the
report the other point that I would make
is that the report was on free @ free
attachments with an email that
monitoring officer sent held on the 14th
of November so I am surprised and I'd be
surprised if too many members hadn't
received the report I'm not too sure how
many have read the report but it would
be interesting to find out if when they
didn't receive the report because it's
such an important item whether they
actually contacted the Democratic
Service office who are know we're on
standby to explain the situation and
work there navigate their way through so
that all members had the opportunity of
seeing the report councillor Thank You
Sherman I fast the monitoring officer in
the past if he will send me copies of
emails and he's not communicated with me
at all so I've not had a chance to read
this report at all because he's not
communicating with me even though I've
asked for everything to be sent by Royal
Mail I'm sure they can't expect me to
file on stuff when you don't give me the
information in that case I'll expect you
to abstain thank you so if I can
introduce
mr. Howells director of corporate
governance and monitoring officer in
order that he can introduce his report
thank you
this is it this is a point of order I
find it quite outrageous actually that's
a member of this chamber can say that
she's had problems accessing this
information and that you quite
cavalierly say that it's not an issue
and you expect her to abstain I think
that's that's not a point of order I'm
sorry
we need the constitute we have this
discussion before it needs to be a point
of order that's by the Constitution
no sorry sit down counselor its point of
order do you really not think it's
important that members of this chamber
should actually have access to important
information I do indeed and they haven't
got access to information do you not
think as chair you should take sorry
Louie can I explain yeah answer my
question please sit down and I'll answer
your question thank you thank you sir I
just thought I'd explained if people if
members hadn't accessed the report then
the right course of action would have
been to report it to Democratic services
the agenda was issued in accordance with
the Constitution all members had the
opportunity of contacting Democratic
services have they had an issue and I
would remind members that this council
went paperless in order that we do not
send information out by post and
certainly we don't send out pinkey
information on posts now can we move on
unless it's a legitimate point of order
counselors can you sit down and I'll
read the point of order rules from the
Constitution so you're aware of what a
point of order is thank you just
equality act if you don't allow other
people to receive information in
alternative can you sit down ours our
stand up and we'll move
right I'll read the Constitution to you
and then you can decide whether it's a
point of order or not Constitution 16.1
free point of order a member may raise a
point of order at any time the Chairman
will hear them immediately a point of
order may only relate to an alleged
breach of these council rules of
procedure or the law the member must
indicate the rule or law and what in
which way she or he considers it has
been broken now I've been very generous
in the past because I don't think any of
the point of orders that have been
raised in the last two meetings have in
fact been point of orders thank you the
ruling of the Chairman on this matter is
final so can we move on
Thank You counselor whales soon can I
invert your structure and just say that
I agree with you that actually members
would get in touch if they couldn't read
the report or whether however your
statement wouldn't be on that and
implied that you were expected or
anticipated for particular votes of
particular direction
clear to us under which part the
Constitution you wish you at stricter
sorry that was badly worded I apologize
for that counselor counselor Piper Thank
You mr. chairman the point of order I
was going to raise before your
explanation but I'll try it anyway is
article 5 specifically 5.01 paragraphs
two three and four
for the benefit of members who might not
be able to instantly recall it paragraph
two to preside over me it's describing
your role mr. chairman to preside over
the meetings of the council so it's
business can be carried out efficiently
with regard to the rights of counselors
and the interests of community I believe
some members feel that generous as you
are mr. chairman occasionally it feels
like debate is being stifled paragraph
three to ensure the council meeting is a
forum for the debate of matters of
concern to the local community
think some members may feel that
stifling debate serves no good purpose
and for to promote public involvement in
the council's activities finally for you
mr. chairman may I include paragraph 5
when describing the role of the Chairman
it says you have to be the conscience of
this council on that point mr. chairman
you have both my empathy and my sympathy
on this issue thank you very much and
I'll share my sleepless nights with you
occasionally
thank you can I need to move on I need
to move on I can't you know I need to
get the monitoring office's report
underway and the rule or the
constitutional rule we're not someone
who has been here a long time and has
worked on the Constitution I'm also very
well aware that we signed up to the
equalities Act of 2010 which week over
at every meeting if you are going to
advise an officer counselor not at that
she has missed out and she needs to
abstain tonight that breaches our
equalities I think we've explained
though I have apologized we've
apologized accountant the counselor but
also if there are other members in here
who haven't read this you should be a
journeying the meeting so that people
can read it now that's the normal course
of course of events is no telling
people's account vote no sorry we're
moving on monitoring officer thank you
chairman members will be aware that on
the 15th october council considered a
report which requested them to undertake
their miss the abbe mistress of action
of declaring a vacancy for the Margaret
Central Ward it became clear at that
meeting that there was some confusion
amongst members about that report and
their ministers except that was actually
required from the council with hindsight
is that setted by officers that the
report could have contained more
detailed background information which
would have hopefully avoided confusion
and assisted members in agreeing this
administrative process following that
decision by counts on the 15th of
October a meeting was held with the
group leaders where it was agreed that a
possible way forward was to delegate the
decoration of vacancy to officers
on the 6th of November council
considered a report which recommended
that delegation but members did not
agree that delegation and that clearly
is within their rights to not grieve a
delegation however in the absence of a
decision on the vacancy
it was my legal duty as marketing
officer to prepare this report for this
evening
I do not propose to go through my report
in a detail I hope and expect that given
that copies were fly the earlier the
more readied but I would point you out
to the summary section 811 and my
recommendation the council declare the
vacancy for the ward forthwith thank you
chairman Thank You councillor Piper
Thank You general I just wondered if I
might have been a bit premature were you
about to propose and get it seconded
what's going on I'm sorry for that chat
I propose that one the council consider
the report by the monitoring officer and
to the counts will declare a vacancy in
the office of counselor for the Margate
central ward with the vice chairman
please respond
second that chair thank you do members
wish to discuss the monitors report
councillor Piper Thank You mr. chairman
I suspect I'm like a great many members
in this chamber this evening and feel
that we need to move on to the business
of doing what we are legally obliged to
do with regard to the declaration
however I have a problem with the
monitoring officers report I have had
emails exchanges with him and shown
beyond doubt that in 5.3 on page 13
where he says the external legal advice
was offered to group leaders on the 22nd
he is mistaken it was not I should know
I was at the meeting we were given
copies of the legal advice on the 12th
of November and the CMT meeting and
email traffic to him concerning that
advice as well as issues pertaining to
the briefing notes that he
she began on the 13th and 14th of
November it is inconceivable that
leaders who have been requesting the
information for weeks would somehow
refuse to accept it or miss the fact
that it was available for scrutiny in
the manner being suggested a review of
the tape from the council meeting of the
6th of November will show that at that
meeting I specifically asked for a copy
of straightforward legal advice and
definition it is inconceivable I would
have asked that if I was already aware
of its production given the mistake in
their support which years hitherto
refused to rectify it is inconceivable
that I can accept this document when it
is factually incorrect mr. chairman
turning to the recommendation because I
believe there are a number of members in
this chamber who might have a problem
with the report but be less inclined not
to make the declaration I respectfully
request that the two parts of this
proposal be formally separated section 5
of the local government and Housing Act
1989 says only that the monitoring
officer has a duty to prepare a report
to the authority it does not say the
report should be used in this way by
separating the two issues of the report
and the declaration mr. chairman it
would leave me and any other members who
share my concerns free to reject the
report by vote and still be comfortable
declaring the vacancy it means we could
declare the vacancy without inferring
any legitimacy to the call to note the
disqualification all the requirements to
make the declaration based on our
acceptance of a report which is after
all only offered for us to consider I
fear mr. chair of the all-or-nothing
approach is leading us nowhere
apart from perhaps another rejection
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You kalsa
Piper
chief executive to respond just firstly
I think probably it's perfectly
acceptable for you to do with those
items separately if as a council you
wish to do that
however before we get to that point i do
feel obliged to actually I recognize
councillor Piper that's your view of the
meeting of the 22nd of October and that
it's your view that the monitoring
office report reflects inaccurately
however I have to say that I was also at
that meeting and I do recall very
clearly that the the legal advice was
available either meeting because I
insisted that it was available at that
meeting and then it was referenced
however I do understand that that
meeting resulted in a discussion or a
range of a number of things and
therefore I genuinely believe perhaps at
that meeting there was some different
views about what was available and what
was available but I do think I do have
to accurately state that the legal
advice was available on the 22nd for
October for people who are at that
meeting to view Council metaphase I have
to agree with counselor Piper I was at
that meeting and rest assured if the
council's advice had been available in a
copy I would have taken a copy it may
have been mentioned in passing but
certainly I have absolutely no
recollection of being offered a copy and
I feel like councilor Piper that that's
an inaccurate
I'm sure mr. house did have the big
advice and I'm sure you did yourself
chief executive but I certainly was not
offered a copy or told that a copy could
be sent to me by email or by as a paper
document thank you
counselor Beaufort 1st and then
counseling yeah Thank You Jen I'm not
sure that they shall help in any way
whatsoever but I was at that meeting and
I honestly can't remember whether it was
offered or not and what I can tell you
know what I can tell you is that the
tone of that meeting was very different
you know I mean as far as I remember
that meeting we were actually trying to
find a way around this and that was the
one where we came up with the notion
that the power could be delegated to the
chief executive so at that point as far
as I was concerned what the meeting was
trying to do was to find a way through
to actually complete this administrative
act so you know in a way we are rather
dancing on the head of a pin again I
think where this is concerned and I
would agree with counts the piper that
what we need to do is move this on get
the declaration made which should have
been done weeks ago because it is a fact
that this council I think has made
itself a little bit daft to the outside
world
but is also denied the people of Margate
the opportunity to be properly
represented democratically and that I
think is a big failure Thank You
councillor pin Thank You mr. chairman
yeah I - haven't seen copies of those
and I think that this health situation
could have been avoided had been
monitoring officers on his job properly
in the first place thank you
not really appropriate in I've taken
advice and I've counseled appellate
Piper I was just going to announce
you've already spoken but is it quickly
I was just going to announce that we
agree with your proposal and I was going
to make a secondary repo that proposal
to split the two items for vote I'm
quite prepared to make that proposal so
in the first instance council they fit
yeah chanting off the first time bit
confused here because we're separating
we're separating
the the consideration of the report so
indeed even if somebody like counterpart
was disagreeing with it and finding
fault with it
you must have considered it so it seems
to make kind of de facto we have
considered the bloody sorry we have
considered it Thank You councillor Wells
I wasn't with the chairman actually
which is pretty simple and
straightforward the purpose of this
meeting and I think a lot of previous
meetings was to get a declaration of
vacancy so can I suggest about this is
the Fourth Amendment or order it may be
if we were to take item 2 first we
wouldn't necessarily have to formally
vote on item 1 Thank You councillor
Wells most well full and well welcome
council Johnson Thank You chairman as
those of us who have actually had an
opportunity to read fully the external
legal advice from counsel there's a very
important point here under number 14
page 18 that I need clarification from
mr. house please if you can find it
anybody who's got it it's number 14 page
18 subject to the provisions of section
81 below a person shall be disqualified
for being an elected or being a member
of a local authority if he and it goes
on to say it goes on to don't believe
we're discussing that the same thing we
are
I'm sorry I don't know where of course
we're discussing so the legal advice
external legal advice that we have paid
for is telling us that we know Clare
someone disqualified when I haven't been
interviewed
swimmer in the mess were in I asked for
this item to be withdrawn on the 11th of
October sorry sorry the person I've let
it count sir can we sit down and move on
to the row me out and call the police on
this one if you wish I'm telling you he
was not interviewed by anybody in this
council well we're not discussing there
no yes we are no yes not sit down tell
us so I can make a proposal which will
mean if the vote goes the way I suspect
we won't need to discuss that item you
have disqualified my colleague no I
can't make comment on that at all and
you shouldn't be making comments I
should know I'm sorry I'm pleased you
said there are you sitting down or shall
I stand up I'm sorry thank you can I
propose then that the counts will
declare a vacancy in the office of
counselor for the Margate Central Ward
with the vice chairman please second a
second chair thank you we can now go to
the vote can I ask
Celso Piper mr. chairman thank you very
very much the the the proposal that was
put before us was to do one and then two
and you were about to say you were
prepared to do that before councillor
Wells helpfully intervened it occurs to
me that if we do - first we won't need
to do one exactly so well I really do
want it to be the correct way round
members must have the opportunity to
either because we've considered it we've
discussed it there should be a vote
about the report and then move on to the
declaration of the reason to vote on the
report well it's it's the council
considering the report we're with
separate the issue councils can you
enlighten us can be resistant and
formalized my suggestion will seek a
second for which is that I propose an
amendment that we delete
recommendation 1 and that we leave
recommendation 2 to stand alone thank
you can ask for a vote on councilor
world's proposal all those in favor
all those against thank you abstentions
right that's carried so we've had I've
made a proposal it's been seconded by
the vice chairman so can I ask you to
vote on item to the council declare a
vacancy in the office of the counselor
for the Margate Central Ward all those
in favor
thank you all those against any
abstentions thank you that's carried and
I believe that therefore finalizes the
items of business for this evening at
7:30 9 thank you